hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
Rifts as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots hey let's check in on
Chicago well since it's rediscovery a
couple weeks ago the Chicago Rat Hole
has brought joy to cow Chicagoans who
flocked to the rodent likee impression
in a rock what is the Rat Hole can
somebody I'm not from Chicago can
somebody explain I thought it was a gay
bar judging from the the groom and the
groom hold I thought the rat holes were
all in Manhattan okay no let's come on
Virgie there's plenty of rats in Chicago
too that was that was
pessy what that was pessy that said that
no he said I thought it was a Ratt I
thought he was saying from New York City
yeah he was but pessy said no that was
pessy said that they both sound exactly
the same it's really not your fault it
was like it was very anti-semitic so I
understand how you could get it
mixed obviously we all thought it was
virgy because it was making fun of Jews
a couple weeks ago the Chicago Rat Hole
has brought joy to countless Chicagoans
who flocked to the rodent likee
impression in a Rosco Village sidewalk I
swear to God it is it is literally where
they were concrete no it's not it's I
swear you people in Chicago have
something [__] wrong with your
[__] head you got your priorities all
[__] up what is it it is a [__]
where they were doing the sidewalk and a
rat fell in it and now it's like a thing
so the rat like died in the cement and
then it like indented in and then
there's just like yeah look I swear to
God I just sent you the Wikipedia page
there's a wikip wiip Wikipedia page for
a [__] rat shaped [__] I swear to
[__]
God what the oh yeah your pizza's
[__] and your rat hole is
gay your town sucks okay here you go
here's here's here's the Rat
Hole there you go that's what we're
talking about
they Chicago Rat Hole shap like a on the
sidewalk of West Rosco Street in Rosco
Village neighborhood in
Chicago uh after existing for decades it
became a viral phenomenon on social
media mainly Twitter in January 2024
attracting tourists to the site imagine
going to Chicago to go tour a rat hole
can I read my favorite entry in this
article sure debate over origin of hole
there is doubt that the hole was created
by a rat as some locals believe it was
actually a squirrel the director of
Lincoln Park
wild Institute death Magle black people
are genociding each other every day in
that City and you guys are focusing on
whe it was what kind of rodent made the
hole yeah it might have been yeah yeah
the squirrel
thing yeah but she makes three really
good points the first is that more
likely it was an animal that fell from a
tree a trait common among squirrels but
not
cares who cares yeah but secondly the
impact happened when the cement was
still wet which is typically during day
and arat is a nocturnal animal they're
calling it Chicago's
Stonehenge I'm not kidding that's what
the New York Times called it the seventh
wonder of the world guys vote for uh go
vote for Biden or Michelle Obama
whoever's destroy the country Gavin Nome
he's not all right all right all right
hold on this is America this is Chicago
and America in a nutshell I just sent
you oh damn it it sends a link [__] oh
are you going to send the picture of the
coins with the no oh they have coins in
the thing with estrogen pills with
estrogen pills what did you send it to
me yeah I I don't know if it'll pull it
yeah I think it will is that is that
really estrogen pills
yeah why is this loading like
mypace
um why cuz
Chicago a Chicago Rat Hole
wedding wedding so that's any wedding in
Chicago is a rat hole
wedding hey guys come to my destination
wedding I'm going to
Chicago Bills on Saturday at what's
become Chicago's hottest tourist
attraction there better be a reception
with an open bar after this
[__] Chicago's biggest tourist
attraction is a hoer rat fell in well
yeah because no well I believe it was a
squirrel okay shut the [__]
up I mean it's either the r we either go
to the Rat Hole or we go to King Von's
grave I mean there's not a lot of
options BL Blues Brothers No the rat the
chicag okay was
like I know Rat Hole I think the Rat
Hole is a gift that keeps on giving is
it Lupe Fiasco concert there you go
that's Chicago wouldn't be caught dead
in [__] Chicago course not Raj seroy
and his wedding planner Leica sok Keen
all those words those aren't work you
just said a bunch of gibberish who are
these people are there white people
anymore that hole is a gift that keeps
on giving you talking about your
extended stretched [__] yeah hole it
never stops giving yeah
seriously Raj shery and [__] [__]
looks like buttered chicken his wedding
planner Lea soken say l SE
King and his partner looked at a lot of
Chicago
land marks for their wedding until days
are
gross wait also when he saw the story of
the Chicago Rat Hole we were viewing a
lot of different venues a lot of
different you know what I would
do I would go fill it overnight that
would be so I would fill it with conrete
and what's the city going to do it's not
you know how easy it is to mix up a
little quick cre yeah yeah do some quick
crate we fill it up and take everything
from them that would be so [__] funny
dude [__] you and your rat hole you know
God you know why this is popular because
Chicago has nothing else because it was
there for like 30
years so they didn't redo this sidewalk
here for 30 years for [__] 30 years
well we can't we have the rat hole it's
a [__] it's part of the historic
district mhm in Chicago and finally we
looked at each other and we were honey
where do you want to go this year we
want to take the kids so do you want to
take them to the Arlington Cemetery or
to the Chicago Rat Hole hey let's get
married at the Rat Hole when he came to
me with honest neither yeah you're right
yeah you know I was like hey you want to
go to Arlington so we can fetishize all
these dead guys that died for Foreign
Wars no thanks we're going to the rat
hole Yeah deep dish great you know we
can make this happen and pizza soup and
they're super enthusiastic about it for
those who don't know the rat hole is a
rodent shaped dent in the cement in the
figured it out we did it we got it on
our own without you the under block of
West Rosco that's been there for at
least 20 years but a couple weeks ago
Chicago we celebrate the spot where this
squirrel got chemical burns cuz we live
in Chicago it's very weird right cuz
it's such a morbid
thing but a couple weeks ago Chicago
artist Winslow du main came across the
rat hole and posted it on X of Twitter
Twitter post that was quickly viewed by
over 5 million people and turned the rat
hole into an international sensation I
think there's a lot of meaning behind it
as well you know what there's none
there's no meaning there's no meaning
behind it [__] rodent fell probably a
squirrel from a tree stop with a
squirrel it was a rat it was absolutely
a squirrel not doing this it had to fall
from high enough up that the impact
would make the Deep of an impression it
was yeah where rats climbing trees look
at the [__] and look at the shape of
the body not it's a squirrel it's a
squirrel I'm on team squirrel this rat
died for our city of
Chicago and I wanted to pay my respects
did they print that out and and like
glue it Raj and his partner did by
holding part of their wedding with
dozens of others gathered to pay homage
tell me you're cheap without saying
you're cheap shortly after they were
mugged by a bunch of
illegals oh but there was actually this
is like having a wedding at that weird
shitty eyesore building on I4 the the I4
iur B ship like a sale they spent all
this money in but it's been empty for
like I don't know about 10 years now
large crowd there so there was there's
no better symbolic place for a gay
marriage than a spot where a [__] rat
died yeah yeah well squirrel but yeah
squirrel but you know I mean what is a
squirrel but a tree rat yeah there's
probably 50 people they were very nice
people they kind of made room for us
they they you know gave us an Applause
and if you think the rat Paul has
officially jumped what about
chipmunk is there chipmunks in Chicago
were there chipmunks in Chicago 30 years
ago I don't know vergie the shark Raj
says it delivered I would never take it
back it's just an amazing great day that
I will remember for the rest of my
life why do everything have to be
[__] weird hipster [__] now it's all
like this weird gay hipster [__]
Chipmunks are on the table boys
Chipmunks are in the
midwest it could have been a chipmunk it
could have been a
chipmunk hole could have been a chipmunk
hole
yep [__] Roc cracking the Rat Hole
code armor door armor do said just wrote
comes just wrote Come okay
okay